dude who who won 2018 olympia this guy
dude his abs are black he looks
weird how come that's okay but blackface
isn't they are allowed to wear that
stuff that makes your skin look dark
so you can see the muscles better right
but they get to a point where it's
literally it's black face it's black
body and we just accept it
well not only that like you have to
pretend you're one color yeah you do
either i accept the fact that you're in
chocolate body and chocolate face what
is that
that's not real i think that might be
real he totally didn't go chocolate face
chocolate body look at this they're
they're literally spray tanning these
people exactly what they're doing
they're turning that guy black
listen man i get it black eyes look
better you're just gonna have to deal
with you see the muscle fiber i agree
just be white chocolate body
why is it okay nice chocolate bonnie
and black are we the first ones to ever
say
this oh look at that lady total
chocolate face how dare you dude
that is the most chocolate face she's
dark chocolate face
damn dude that's okay hold on
you tell me this [ __ ] is okay she's a
fitness competition
it's okay bro it's a fitness account all
right i'll do an olympia next week
i'm just showing you how ripped my face
is
it makes no sense watch your face yo my
face is shredded as [ __ ] son
i chew gum all day bro when i want to
stop i don't
in my [ __ ] cheeks right here is
ripped face is ripped bro look at oh
[ __ ] bro how many people just want to
wear a black face because they're super
racist and they can't so they become
bodybuilders
does that happen dude i'm not saying it
happens a lot but has it happened once
has one guy said yeah i'm just a [ __ ]
bodybuilder bro
get over it man get over it man
yeah get over it he starts like rapping
and [ __ ]
oh for all you bodybuilders out there we
don't really care no keep doing your
chocolate bodies yeah don't encourage it
because it's hilarious
and it makes you look better you're
right it's an advantage chocolate it up
bro yeah you're right who wants to be
more chocolate and the only reason why
you should go chocolate face is because
otherwise it's super distracting
no i don't think you're tan i think
you're crazy yeah you're
crazy what's going on like what the [ __ ]
do you have like a suit on